one get to be self-aware make the people
closest to you feel comfortable to tell
you the truth tell your mom and dad and
spouse best friend co-worker hey
tell me the truth what am I good at what
am I bad at and spend a month or two to
get them comfortable to actually tell
you the truth because the people that
love you sure don't want to tell you
like you literally tell them like no I
know Johnny I know you're my best friend
and I know you think I'm just joking
when you're about to on me right
now you think I'm gonna flip and you're
gonna blame me for putting you in that
position but I'm telling you the truth I
don't know if I'm a good artist or I
don't know if I'm good at this job just
tell me what you think and then also
doing that with 10 people because you
know that people have different opinions
that's been one of the things I've
thought about creating a safety net for
people that know you best to actually
give you candorous feedback but not
letting one opinion in that environment
carry the day getting that from 10
people and then if all 10 of them say
that you're a little lazy and you don't
see it there's probably a good chance
you're lazy